what are you gonna say when the general
manager says hey - you know everything
looks good you look healthy but three
lower body injuries at Alabama
it's big-boy leaf now if you can't stay
healthy there you're not gonna stay
healthy yeah what are you gonna say when
they start pushing you that way well I
was in Bionic then I'm Bionic now -
talking about Lola back in January with
this the Super Bowl my god that was a
long time ago it feels like it was a
hell of a lot longer ago than it was
talking about the concerns about his
health great kid great attitude bad
circumstances he's got a hip problem
that people can't personally examine the
team doctors can't look at him the team
doctors who are accountable to the teams
it would be burning the draft picks
Chris they can't give the teams the up
or down go get him or stay away and that
has prompted many to believe that maybe
to otunga Vella is destined to plunge
out of the top ten Nick Saban the head
coach in Alabama who got the most out of
Tonga by llola during his college career
told Andrew Beaton of the Wall Street
Journal that anybody who passes on Tong
of Aloha is making a mistake we failed
Drew Brees on the physical Saban says
that's why he's not Miami's quarterback
and basically anybody who doesn't take
Tong of Aloha is gonna suffer the same
fate the Dolphins have over the past 15
years by not having Drew Brees but
instead of a revolving door of guys that
they have just hoped would become a
franchise quarterback your thoughts on
what Saban had to say well I mean you
know again that's like you know hash tag
what do you expect him to say a little
bit and I don't think he's like lying
but of course he's gonna talk positively
about a quarterback who one of a
national championship you know got him
to another national championship and
certainly you know this past year they
were one of the best teams in college
football once again you know as we've
seen and we got to witness in person you
just you referred to it it's a very
charismatic you know got a good nature
about him hey he's he's got all those
things you know as far as what you see
Juana is a quarterback a leader you know
the ability to talk and communicate and
and just show charisma all that is all
so you know and I believe you know Nick
Saban and what he's saying but it
doesn't change the fact of the matter
the fact of the matter is we're talking
about what five or six surgeries Mike I
know we both heard from people around
the NFL that there's there's a there's a
rumor out there that people think he
needs another surgery on his ankle he's
not necessarily the biggest human being
we've ever seen before - and it's not
like he's Tyler Marie or Lamar Jackson
as far as running around and doing
things like that so you know again hey
you know Nick Saban we may maybe it is
Drew Brees well I don't know but there's
a lot more here to be concerned about
with Toula than there was a Drew Brees
or is just the shoulder and we haven't
seen to do it in the NFL yet - and
there's a difference there as well and
here's the big difference between Drew
Brees and Toa
back in early 2006 when the Dolphins
were deciding what to do at quarterback
their doctors had the opportunity to
examine Drew Brees they screwed it right
they came to a bad conclusion but at
least it was an informed conclusion that
someone could put his or her name on the
bottom line - and that person probably
did not remain the Dolphins physician
for a very long time after that
but at least you could come to your own
conclusion with Toa you are flipping a
coin you are taking a chance you are
throwing a dart because you can't come
to your own conclusion as to whether or
not he's healthy this Saints had a
chance to examine Drew Brees and they
decided they're fine with the physical
risk do you think the Saints would have
signed Drew Brees Kris if if if Tom
Condon contacted Sean Payton and Mickey
Loomis back in 2006 and said Drew Brees
would really like to play for the Saints
he'd like to be an integral part in the
rebirth of the city following Katrina we
just have one request you can't give him
a physical before you sign him know what
the Saints have said if that was how it
was presented to them yes you know
you're right they would have gone well
no sorry you know we're gonna have to go
down another Avenue and find another
quarter
we can't just you know throw a dart on
the wall and hope hey I hope drew brees
his shoulder is okay you know again so
you know there's just a lot of things at
play here let alone and you know Mike
I've heard this you know I think there's
a number of teams that have already
failed him for his medical and they
won't look at him in the first round now
the teams that need quarterbacks they're
not gonna film on their medical and
there's gonna be you know some due
diligence and they're gonna find a way
to make themselves feel comfortable
about the to a situation because they
have a quarterback need and to me this
is one of the fascinating things of the
draft in two days what happens with to
it you know when he falls out of the top
ten which I fully expect him to but once
he gets the number ten business is gonna
be open for to it and who is gonna be
that owner that just can't help it is
gonna be sitting there in the draft room
going look look he's there all I've
heard about is - up - up - up for two
years he's the greatest thing since
sliced bread we gotta get him we gotta
get him and I just feel like there's
gonna be an owner that's gonna take that
cheese and he'll go somewhere between 10
and 20 because of the of the player and
of course just the what do I want to say
might be attention in the grandiosity
around a guy like Tula and Alabama and
you know my case there I mean I think
people give a little too much credit for
Tula for the great machine that is
Alabama but regardless I think it's one
of the most intriguing things of this
draft and you know what yeah
you gave me a thought there while you
were talking about the market opening
for - at number 10 is it possible yeah
that a team now now that look it's one
thing to say we'd like to trade down you
have to find someone who wants to trade
up but what if you're a team in the top
ten they would be thinking about - if
you had a chance to properly evaluate
his hip and you're not comfortable
rolling the dice with a top ten pick but
you could slide back we always think
about teams jumping up to get it right
what about sliding back and getting a
guy with a lower pick a lesser
investment less of a risk
and you pick up something else to
balance out that risk by virtue of the
trade back well I I mean I think that's
real I mean yeah the Chargers right
there are a team that you know would
they think about doing that you know I
would say they have a greater need at
offensive tackle right now than they do
with the quarterbacks in those position
but yeah I hear you there Mike would
they trade down with somebody you know
the Miami Dolphins of course with their
three first-round picks they'll be able
to do whatever they want trade up trade
down whatever the hell they want to do
they're gonna be able to do that if
that's what they wanted to do you know
but the big thing is to me to that's
also fascinating in this draft Mike is
who who is the great commodities that
everybody's gonna trade up into the top
ten to get that's where I don't know
right now you know yes the offensive
linemen I think there's gonna be a run
of em at the top ten you know I think we
could see those two defensive tackles
Kinlaw and Brown and have a little run
in the top ten but that's the media
another fascinating part of this draft
who are the people that people want to
aggressively trade up and give assets to
get and I'm not sure those people exist
in this draft and that's what's a little
different than maybe yours past or if
they do it's a lot easier this year to
keep it quiet remember three years ago
yeah we found that we didn't find out at
the time but we found out after the fact
how much the Chiefs and the Saints loved
Patrick mahomes they managed to keep it
quiet
it's easier to keep it quiet when
there's no pro day workouts where scouts
are gathered around and they're shooting
the breeze and maybe people that you
shouldn't be trusting with information
have information and they're running
their mouths because they're trying to
advance a relationship with someone with
this other team in the event they end up
getting fired after the draft in the
Atlantic spot these are all real factors
that result in information flowing
between human beings with everyone on
lockdown it's easier to keep it quiet so
you know Chris with limited information
what you're gonna have is cific teams
owners GM's coaches fall in love with a
guy and there's no reason and there's no
way that anyone's gonna know they've
fallen in love with that guy and I think
that's when you
potentially see a strike up to get a guy
that nowhere else is really thinking
about because that team fell in love
with him regardless of what the other 31
teams did or didn't do III hear that you
know I hear that and that's where I
think like you know the kid from Auburn
Derrick brown the defensive tackle he
could be that guy where people just look
at him and go oh I think he's a New Age
Warren Sapp or something like that we
got to get our hands on him you know
that that could be that guy you're right
there's a very very real possibility but
you know that the to a situation
Isaiah Simmons from Clemson Mike you
know the great athlete who plays all
these different positions you know I did
I finished my mock draft yesterday I've
been dabbling and messing around with it
for like four days prior to that you
know and tua and Isiah Simmons to me are
like two of these jokers in the top ten
where I just go I don't know where they
land where they go I'm not sure they go
in the top ten they might fall and I
think they're a big you know factor in
how this whole thing shakes out but it's
why I cannot wait for the draft tomorrow
night it's going to be fascinating a lot
of fun to watch and chances are there is
a team out there that is sold on both
guys more likely on Simmons than Toa but
again the information much easier to
contain this year the teams may realize
and you know what we'd already seen kind
of a push in that direction
we saw fewer coaches at the Scouting
Combine a couple the teams left their
guys at home teams may realize yeah it
is a lot easier to keep the secrets
in-house by not sending the minions out
around the country we could see a
fundamental change in the way the
pre-draft process works I've been to
keep their information quiet
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports